what's going on guys we are back to the
DC Universe side of our Omega and Beyond
Omega level videos and after having to
cover cosmic armor Superman last time
we're gonna take a break from the
insanely convoluted and step back into
the realm of more straightforward
characters but characters that are still
pretty powerful nonetheless now the
reason that we're doing this is because
Martian Manhunter is actually pretty
easy to explain this will probably be
the shortest video that we make he's a
green Martian he has the same powers of
Superman plus telepathy and
shape-shifting and he's scared of fire
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to come as explained make sure
you guys hit the sub button to become
part of the Rob core if you guys enjoyed
this video make sure you drop a like and
I will catch you all later I imagine
people were just like what but in all
seriousness Martian Manhunter is
literally just as his name implies he's
a Martian meaning that he's actually
from Mars not from an alternate universe
or fictional planet
now Martian Manhunter is a product of
the Silver Age of comics making his
debut in Detective Comics number 225 in
1955 when he was pulled to Earth from
Mars
by a teleportation beam constructed by
dr. Saul hurtle I think it's how you
pronounce his last name
now since dr. Earle was the only one who
could actually operate the beam and
because Martian technology was not
advanced enough at the time to allow him
to be rescued the Martian Manhunter was
basically stranded on earth now like
most characters that they viewed during
this time all we really know from his
first appearances is that his Martian
physiology allows him to shape-shift a
power he uses to disguise himself as an
earthling and adopt the alias of Jon
Jones which is conveniently enough the
same spelling of his actual Martian name
but in the following years a lot more
powers would be added to Martian
Manhunter Arsenal including telepathy
precognitive abilities flight and atomic
vision which is basically powerful
energy blasts that he shoots from his
eyes now he also has your standard
superhero powers of super-strength speed
durability and stamina but he's also
developed a weakness to fire but in his
early days he was only susceptible to
that weakness when in his natural
Martian form not when he was in his
disguised form because you know 1950s
comics and I guess it made sense
anyway since he was stuck on earth he
decides that he might as well use his
awesome powers to be a superhero so he
reveals his true identity to the world
and begins fighting crime as the Martian
Manhunter and would become one of the
several founding members of the Justice
League of America a fact that DC Comics
would actually completely ignore when
they launched the new 52 and replaced
him with cyborg as a Justice League
founder but back in the early days of
the JLA DC editorial decided they did
not want to over expose their main
characters like Superman and Batman a
principle that would actually seem crazy
today because these characters are
inserted to a lot of stories but they're
also DC's two most popular characters
but back then
DC wanted to make it a big deal when
Superman or Batman showed up and they
felt that it cheapen the characters if
they were showing up in team books all
the time so Martian Manhunter basically
became a substitute for Superman at the
time meaning anytime a writer would have
previously used Superman in a story or
if they needed someone as powerful as
Superman they would use Martian
Manhunter instead and so he would remain
a mainstay of the JLA all the way up
through the Justice League International
run by Keith Giffen and J M DeMatteis
after crisis on Infinite Earths and
Grant Morrison's run in 1998 now we have
not seen a lot of Martian Manhunter
since the new 52 came along he was
briefly in Stormwatch a book that did
not sell very well and got cancelled he
had a solo series as part of DC u that
ran for about 12 issues and as far as
I'm aware he's not been seen at all in
DC rebirth but while he has not had a
really prominent role in DC Comics for
quite some time he is still one of the
most powerful characters in the DC
Universe and is probably close to the
level of Superman in terms of his
abilities in fact in JL a number 86
Superman actually described the Martian
Manhunter as the most powerful being on
the face of the earth
now we've already touched on what
Martian Manhunter powers are but they've
also evolved so much over the years of
his existence that we've really only
scratched the surface of what he's
capable of as we said he is super strong
and he together with Superman and Wonder
Woman were able to tow the earth behind
them
using Wonder Woman's lasso and his
punches were able to deal damage to
superboy-prime one of the strongest
characters in DC Comics his speed is
such that he's able to travel through
space at near light speed and he's been
shown to be able to keep up with both
Superman and even the flash he's nearly
invulnerable having sustained blows from
Despero a character that's physically
stronger than Superman and in the event
that he is harmed he has an amazingly
powerful regenerative healing factor
which allowed him to regrow his whole
body from a severed arm now in addition
to all this his Martian physiology
allows him to exist for extended periods
of time with no food air or rest now
with shape-shifting abilities extend far
beyond being able to take up the form of
any creature seen or imagined but he can
actually alter the density of his body
to make himself either extremely dense
and thereby increases strength and
durability or intangible so that he can
pass through solid objects he can create
powerful beams of energy from his eyes
he has a remarkable lung capacity that
allows him to create powerful gusts of
wind and freeze his enemies and he has
x-ray vision
now what sets him apart from Superman is
his telepathy his ability to read minds
is so advanced that he was able to
simultaneously read the minds of
everyone on earth and is even been able
to read the mind of the Spectre who's
basically the physical manifestation of
God's vengeance in the DC Universe he's
also an extremely potent telekinetic and
has used his ability to create both
force fields and offensive blasts of
psionic energy now as we mentioned
earlier the Martian Manhunter does have
a weakness which comes in the form of
fire but this has been written really
inconsistent over the years and he has
ranged from cowering at the site of fire
to pretty much being immune to fire
unless it's mystical in nature but as
best I can tell the current continuity
dictates that fire will not actually
harm Martian Manhunter physically
instead he's basically scared of it
because the Martian race was destroyed
by fire but nonetheless Martian
Manhunter has been and continues to be
one of the most powerful beings in DC
Comics and anyone who's arguably as
strong or stronger than Superman
definitely deserves to be on our list of
and Beyond omega-level characters now
the question is is he omega or is he
beyond Omega level well remember beyond
Omega level basically means that a
character is a universal threat meaning
the third power would allow them to
presumably control the universe lay
waste to the universe destroy almost
anybody in the universe things along
those lines
Omega level means that they are well
beyond being a planetary threat so I
would say that Martian Manhunter is
Omega level I wouldn't say that he's
beyond Omega level Martian Manhunter is
not someone who's as powerful as like
the white Lantern for example he's just
not on that level of ability which of
course means that Superman's around the
same around the same place anyway guys
if you are new here to comments explain
make sure you guys with the sub button
to become part of the Rob core if you
guys enjoyed this video make sure you
drop a like and yeah I will catch you
all later please
[Music]